[Musique]
celle en quelques instants ça va être
votre fête comme les choses dit on file
au musée grévin achats d'or bah oui on
est fils matt alors tatar place et à
statut voilà et a passé l'après-midi le
faire ça c'est une demi heure pas très
bien quand même
le résultat doit être bon bah j'espère
mais normalement magnéto est censé
parler permet pas de faire du duplex
avec c'est à vous élancer manière
choisie ou le magnéto de m pokora bajeux
les mêmes montées et près des monts
[Applaudissements]
allez zou l'égard non au régime
on est comme en régie qu'on appelle dans
le jargon le off pokora 1
j'adore parce que en régie me disent on
est cadet à la map vous avez votre
statue de cire là bas aujourd'hui c'est
un jour particulier puisque c'était
deuxième pis pour le prix dans votre
statut était un peu les oreilles mais
vous avez accepté de la remplacer au
pied levé et je vous remercie infiniment
ainsi que le musée grévin
regardez ma de poids normal
[Musique]
au niveau mental des gauches
bonjour oui
[Musique]
c'est non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ac on voit que matt aussi il est drôle
il a la classe
si on fait jamais trop long mais c'est
vrai on aurait pu apprendre à relooker
ou pas je l'aurais fait face à luca le
mec il est lourd matt hill et il est bon
partout
non mais sans rire je te voyais à la
fois dans l'émission d'arthur de
vendredi tout est permis
je vous disais d'un mac il a quand même
la classe il est drôle avant dé qui sort
un truc vam ilan en lucarne
non mais c'est vrai c'est pour ça qu'on
t'aime c'est pour ça qu'il n'en a pas on
parle football du ghana c'est vrai je te
le dire car délai les deux côtés ils
sont plus beau est là sans déconner on
dirait qu'on va défiler les de la
dresser les bogdanoff mais beau gosse
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
ça
on a la version bibliothèque et la
version quand ils vont chercher du bois
normalement et amati se retourne vers de
leurs ventes à chercher une bûche toutes
les firmes
[Rires]
[Musique]